A.M.C. has put out more than its fair share
of hit television shows in the past several
years, but the undisputed cornerstone of the
network remains "The Walking Dead."
Debuting on October 31, 2010, the program
offered a dramatic new spin on the zombie
genre by putting the focus on the human survivors
and their lives with one another and using
the reanimated masses - which aren't even
called "zombies" in the show - as a backdrop.
This approach made the series a pop culture
phenomenon in no time and propelled it for
over a decade.
While "The Walking Dead" is immensely popular,
it isn't exactly a show that's accessible to everyone.
The collapse of modern society and the rise
of flesh-hungry corpses known as "walkers"
are enough to turn off viewers who are sensitive
to such content.
Factor in the excessive blood, gore, and general
violence that constantly follow the characters,
elaborate special effects that make death
scenes look far too real, and the series'
use of well-time jump scares, and you've got
a recipe for a show that is just too much
for some people.
For the majority of "Walking Dead" viewers,
this content comes with the territory, and
there are no complaints to be had.
However, there are a few odd scenes that unsettled
even the most committed fans - and many have
confessed that a few "Walking Dead" moments
went way too far.
We here at Looper were curious about the "Walking
Dead" fandom's picks for its most stomach-churning scenes.
We polled viewers and according to our results,
almost 28% of respondents agreed that Negan
Smith brutally killing Glenn Rhee and Abraham
Ford was the hardest moment to handle.
For those who don't recall, in the Season
7 premiere, ominously and aptly entitled "The
Day Will Come When You Won't Be," Negan taunts
Rick Grimes and his group of fellow survivors,
who he has ordered to kneel on the ground
and declare their loyalty to him.
He chooses Abraham to make an example of,
using his barbed-wire-covered bat Lucille
to bludgeon him in the head.
When Daryl Dixon attempts to take a stand
and attack Negan, the bat wielding maniac
has a simple response.
"That, oh my.
That is a no-no."
Then, of course, things go from bad to worse.
Negan decides that the group needs to be further
punished, and he selects Glenn as his next victim.
He kills him without mercy, in the same way
that he did to Abraham.
The brutal deaths of Glenn and Abraham have
been remembered in infamy, and even one of
the "Walking Dead" stars involved in the scene
thought it went too far.
During an appearance on the "Talk Dead to
Me" podcast, Abraham actor Michael Cudlitz
revealed his true feelings.
"I always think it was a bridge too far, personally.
I thought it was too much.
Either one of us should have lived a little
bit longer, because people were very affected by it."
Cudlitz added that he knows more gruesome
deaths happened in "The Walking Dead," but
Glenn and Abraham's struck viewers because
they truly cared about the characters.
"There were a lot of other killings and murders
and lives lost on the show that were a lot more brutal.
[But] the fact that I think you loved Abraham
and Glenn so much as an audience, that's what
makes it more brutal."
Unsurprisingly, for a show as gory as "The
Walking Dead," Negan's bloody executions weren't
totally unopposed in our poll about which
scenes went too far.
The Season 3 episode "Killer Within" also
ranks high.
It deals with the death of Rick's wife Lori,
who had to undergo an emergency C-section,
courtesy of Maggie Greene, to save her baby.
That gut-wrenching scene culminates with Lori
and Rick's son Carl killing his mom before
she returns as a walker.
From there, the picks don't get any less heartbreaking.
The runners-up include Rick killing Sophie
in her walker form in front of her mom, along
with Carol shooting the severely disturbed
Lizzie.
And finally, Noah's demise at the hands of
a zombie horde rounds out the list.
With more than 150 episodes to look back on,
this is surely just the tip of the iceberg
when it comes to the show testing the limits
of cable television guidelines.
Now that its historic run will wrap up in
2022, one has to wonder if "The Walking Dead"
will try to push the envelope one more time
or have mercy on its fans and give us a hopeful ending.
Either way, it's going to be tough to say
goodbye to the show and all its surviving characters.
"It's an emotional moment.
I get it."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
shows are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.